when immigration immigration customs and
enforcement announced last night that it
had just wrapped a three-day sweep that
netted a hundred and fifty illegal
aliens many of you were probably
cheering but Oakland Mayor Libby Schaaf
was not amused
last weekend mayor shaft took the
extraordinary step of sending out a
public notice that warned immigrants and
their families of the impending ice
raids I continue to feel confident that
what I did was the right thing and it
was legal I did not give specific
information that could have endangered
law enforcement I encouraged people to
not panic
but to know their rights to know their
responsibilities and to know about the
unique resources that are available in
this community now according to that
warped view immigration laws are at
their core discriminatory and unfair and
therefore ignoring them or thwarting
them is not only fine it's the honorable
thing to do so get this if you're a
criminal alien there is no better state
to live in than good old California what
Mayor chef did with her illegal
immigrant emergency broadcast bulletin
it wasn't just outrageous it's
potentially criminal ice director Tom
Holman said the Justice Department is
reviewing the possibility of filing
federal charges against the mayor and
the Washington Times headline said lock
Libby up now worried about Hillary later
that was a fun one half of the 150
arrested were convicted criminals and
the charges included gang membership
weapons domestic violence and DUIs but
unfortunately some 864 criminals that
ice was seeking remain at-large in the
Oakland and San Francisco San Francisco
region now some of them undoubtedly fled
the area
after receiving the warning buyer by
mayor chef
well this incensed the ice director Tom
Holman who spoke to Fox and Friends when
politicians choose to take care of their
political ambitions and make political
statements on the backs of law
enforcement it's just terrible it makes
our job more difficult but I'll say this
the mayor and every other politician
that wants to vilify the men and women
of ice we're not going away we're going
to keep enforcing a law of course the
mayor defended her actions calling it
her duty and moral obligation oh please
and she later told the Washington Post I
consider myself a law-abiding citizen I
consider myself a believer in an
American democracy that moves towards a
more just society and I definitely
consider myself part of the resistance
which she's honest resistance the common
sense may be well in doing this Mayor
chef is dancing right on the edge of
obstruction of justice for shamelessly
putting agents police and her neighbors
in danger I really hope that Attorney
General Jeff Sessions is taking a
serious look at this here's the bottom
line because the Oakland mayor put
politics and frankly her sheer hatred of
the president ahead of the rule of law
innocent Californians in legal
immigrants by the way might die be
terribly harmed and I know Oakland is a
you know liberal place fine that's fine
but how does making life easier for
criminal aliens including ms-13 gang
bangers how does it help your community
it's disgraceful and that's the angle